hello everyone welcome back to part 2 of
book club of the infinite game it's a
wonderful group coming from all over the
world we have Canada Harrisburg
Pennsylvania India Berlin Pittsburgh
Melbourne Australia how are you good
morning to you and from the strategic
stripping away book club I feel exactly
the same I also have not been excited
for a book club in my life especially
from when I was a child good to see
everybody
dare I say this at the risk of well I've
really been talking reading this book
maybe it's because I agree with
everything that was written it's been a
good few chapters I have to say so this
time we are live on YouTube LinkedIn and
Facebook which is very cool first
everybody on all those platforms the
three chapters we cover today chapters 3
through 5 cause no cause keeper of the
cause and the responsibility of business
please feel free to put your live
questions in the question box there and
let's go so a little bit about these
chapters so cause no cause which is
chapter 3 so the reason I wrote this
chapter is because the good news is is
our movement is growing and the good
news is is we are putting pressure on
companies to be and consider a sense of
purpose and cause when they build their
companies to be Purpose Driven we're now
at the point where sort of everybody's
seems to have a purpose statement or
vision statement or mission statement
but if you really get down to it we know
we know that a lot of the companies that
write these vision statements and
mission statements don't actually follow
it or believe it so some of them are
well intended leaders who just don't
have the right words and some of them
aren't and so the question is is how can
we tell the difference so what the what
I decided to do is there's look there's
many many many many many fake causes
false causes I decided to just take a
look at some of the more common ones so
that we know how to recognize the
difference for me the big one was this
idea of a moonshot we so often confuse
or even use the term moonshot as if
describing what our cause is
absolutely moon shots are inspiring
absolutely moon shots are big and
audacious but they're achievable there's
still finite land a man on the moon did
that did that in 1969 did that a long
time ago and so you can see when an
organization is finite driven even if
they have big hairy audacious goals like
a moon shot the questions they get stuck
it kind of happened to NASA a little bit
right the moon shot was such a big thing
for everybody the people actually
started to get bored of them we actually
forgot many people have actually been to
the moon we've done we've done it
multiple times but we really don't think
about it it became rote same with the
Space Shuttle it became rote and so the
opportunity is not to just think of new
big things but what is the bigger thing
the context within which that exists but
I thought it was important for us to be
able to recognize the difference keeper
of the cause I we talked about being
vision visionary we talked about being
Purpose Driven but it raises the the
very valid question who in the company
is actually responsible for the purpose
if a company is to be Purpose Driven
like if a company is financially driven
there's someone responsible for that
finances if this company is it's
performance driven there are people who
are responsible for the performance but
if the company is gonna be purpose
driven my question is who's responsible
for the purpose who's the ultimate
single point of accountability and that
really should be this idea of a CVO and
I make this case of a CEO where we don't
really know what they do some do this
some do that summer vision oriented some
are not some are more operationally
oriented and so if we really want our
organizations to be Purpose Driven there
needs to be at some point a single
person it takes personal accountability
for keeping the company on track and if
we look at the leaders that we admire
the people that we consider visionary
leaders where it's your Steve Jobs as
your Richard Branson's folks like that
kept indle what you find is when they
were leading their organizations the
company really was on a strict visionary
path because somebody was keeping them
on that path so if you want to be
infinite minded in the way we're
building our businesses and the way
we're building our economy is we need
somebody who takes accountability now we
get to my favorite chapter chapter 5 the
responsibility of business I've talked
lot about the damage that our embracing
of Milton Friedman has done it's not
that Milton Friedman did the damage that
we've embraced the ideas that did the
damage and the problem is his business
and life all of these things are dynamic
and he attempts to articulate the
responsibility of business in quite
frankly something that is way too simple
and coming from somebody like me that's
saying something
you know oversimplify over here the
responsibility of businesses to maximize
profits within the bounds of the rules
oh really
that can't be all of it and if we think
about it the enduring ideas ideas that
are really infinite contribute so Adam
Smith's ideas of capitalism have lasted
for over 200 years that says something
the fact that we're starting to question
Milton Friedman's ideas after 40 years
should also tell us something and so one
of the things that was important was I
didn't want to just bash Milton Friedman
for the damage that he did that was too
easy I wanted to offer an alternative
because as you know if you follow any of
the work that I talked about we don't
want to be against something we want to
be for something I don't be against
Milton Friedman's definition of business
I want to be for a different definition
of business the question is is what is
that definition and so I attempted to
write one what I wrote the
responsibilities of business is to use
its will and resources to advance a
cause greater than itself protect the
people and places in which it operates
and generate more resources so that it
continue can it can continue doing all
those things for as long as possible and
I added this part an organization can do
whatever it likes to build a business so
as long as it is responsible for the
consequences of its actions because I
got tired of having debates with people
who who celebrate Milton Friedman's
definition of business when I say aren't
those ethical ethically questionable
decisions you're making and they'd
always tell me copy an mTOR buyer beware
it's up to the consumer to decide well
sometimes it's not that easy for us
especially when we rely to manipulated
when they change the the
partially hydrogenated oil to something
else so that we can't recognize it I
mean companies are slick I I was in the
the aisle of the supermarket not too
long ago and I was looking at at healthy
cereals and for some reason we think
because a company is making healthy
products that they're better companies
mm-hmm so I was looking at the same
brand at the chocolate and vanilla
version of the same cereal so that the
the size of the the cereal was the same
you'll understand why that's important
in a second and the chocolate one said
now with less fat or now like oh only
two grams of fat whatever it said we're
sugar they would shirk whatever it is so
I just decided to look on the side of
the package at the at how it at all of
the the the nutritional information and
sure enough there it was the chocolate
one had way less sugar than the plain
one and then I looked at the serving
size one was a cup the other was a third
of a cup like you've got to be kidding
me who eats a third of a cup of cereal
number one and the reason it was the
same sized cereal so it's not like there
was like more little bits of cereal in
is the same thing they had manipulated
the size of the serving so that they
could make a claim on their packaging
that this one had less sugar
that's called a lie it's called
manipulation and they need to be held
responsible there are no standards
unfortunately for this stuff which
drives me absolutely crazy and so I want
to take your questions we'll talk about
the kind of capitalism we have now
versus the kind of capitalism that the
people on this call I'm sure all
completely agree with which is a
different form of capitalism than we
have now I'm not anti capitalist I'm
very Pro capitalist I'm just in favor of
a different form of the capitalism that
we embrace today okay hello Egypt in
Bangkok in Minnesota and Texas and
Pakistan Wow I just love how this
message spreads far and wide you know
why because it's relevant to human
beings it's not about culture it's about
us we all share these same ideals okay
questions let's jump right in
Kelly creepier from our ever-loyal
dakota potato peel pie and literary
society good to see you again thanks for
the shoutout
here's another one here's the scene say
you're interviewing for a job with a
good company but they don't have a
clearly defined just
what words can we use to uncover their
cause if they're not familiar with my
work so you can ask them what is the
world that you guys imagine I sometimes
ask this question when I've been in the
room with some people same idea which is
can you tell me that if everything were
to go perfectly in this organization can
you tell me what the world would look
like in five to ten or twenty years what
is the world that you imagine that
you're trying to build that may or may
not have anything to do with the product
that's and sometimes get them talking
and if they get stuck they'll sometimes
say well we want to be a big company you
can interrupt and say no no no I want
you to guys have great success but what
contribution to the world will you be
making what is what are you trying to do
in the world besides enrich yourselves
that that sometimes helps it doesn't
have to it's not a necessarily
aggressive a rude line of questioning
but that can really help here we have
one from Iona Bock from Brazil how are
you
obrigado for your question after reading
your book I realize there are more
examples of male leaders than female
leaders maybe because gender equality is
not quite a rule in seal in the sea
levels from another perspective
we heard that countries with female
leaders dealt with the Cova 19 pandemic
better with that in mind how do you see
inclusion of diversity initiatives
helping companies play with the infant
mindset oh such a good question
so I've said this I've said this before
there are traditionally female
characteristics like maternal instinct
carrying patients things like that
there are traditionally male
characteristics things like aggression
decisiveness and it's not that we need
more female leaders that we need more
leaders that act like females and women
just happen to be better at that the the
leadership qualities that I talk about
patients in you know caring instinct
things like that
more tend to be women's happen to have a
better time with that and through my
experience with my work over the years
quite frankly especially with start with
why women on
did that work much quicker than men I
would give a big speech in the early
days of start with why and all the women
would just be nodding yes totally get it
and the men would raise their hand and
say what proof do you have
and so when we have female leaders you
tend to you tend to see those those
things happen more and in the case of
kovat Taiwan Germany New Zealand they
took a much more maternal patient
approach and they have quite frankly
done a hell of a lot better job there's
a whole article about it in Forbes
magazine then many of their male
counterparts now I'll tell you a funny
little color corollary in the Marine
Corps at OCS they run their their future
leaders through a little mini obstacle
courses they call it the LRC leadership
reaction course and they've discovered
that there's a difference between when
the men run it and the women run it it's
it's a timed event yeah it's a time time
things here's what they discovered with
with the men the men don't spend enough
time planning they make a decision too
quickly they end up choosing the wrong
plan and they end up failing the women
spend too much time planning they come
up with the right answer but they don't
need enough time to execute so they end
up failing in other words what makes
great teams is a blend of those things
on the frustration and the tension of
those two things so doorbell I'll ignore
it don't worry about it so yeah we need
more female dynamics of women just
happen to be better at that than men
okay Noah max from the echo ensemble
book club nice to see you you share that
the CEO should really be called the CVO
um how does a CVO find and prepare a
successor during their own tenure to
lead the organization in the future how
does one do this without aggravating the
current CFO co-operators such a good
question well as I talked about in the
book we have this notion that it's a
single line of hierarchy it's really two
parallel lines and so we should get
comfortable with the fact that there
there is a sort of a there's they go
together
and there they're a team and some of the
best organizations I've I've
seen the CEO or the CFO is a really
strong ego to say look I'm really good
at my job I'm the best in my industry at
my job but that's not what I'm
that's not my gift what what what that
person does but we make a great team and
unfortunately unfortunately because that
that CVO mentality is so far looking
ahead all the time that they look at the
the operator minded person and they and
they and they anoint them it's happened
all the time even the visionary leaders
that we like anoint their their
operators because they say quite
legitimately that person knows more than
I do about the business true they
understand how it works better than I do
true they know how to get things done
better than I do true except for the
fact that it's the wrong skillset and
and so I think what we need to do is
start one of the things we need to do in
our organizations to choose our
successors is talk about the skill sets
that we need in both those jobs and that
CVO job is the ability to see Ford's you
might see marketers come up into that
CVO Lou Gerstner who transformed IBM he
came up through the marketing ranks
that's a so you can see the difference
between a Safinaz person and an operator
versus a marketer for example and so we
want to make sure that those those
psychographics there's different
mentalities of the way we approach
problems the way we see the world and by
the way I don't mean all marketers will
make great CEOs and all operators that's
not the case a CVO and CEO can make a
great CFO could make a great CEO if they
take the time and learn the skills to
that their job is going to change the
problem is when you get to that level in
an organization you've worked so hard
doing one thing that to tell somebody
that you have to now completely change
your skill set even though this is
worked very well for you up till now
that's just harder it's not impossible
it's just more difficult hope that helps
let's take loot we got here Jason Quinn
Lee how are you
contributions infinite games partially
if they mess you up once but they mess
you mess them up forever but the
mathematics says forgiving people is
better how do you how we had to record
square that with go so I think I
understand the question Milton Friedman
say it again let me do it let me read it
this one's a tricky one okay Milton
Friedman's contribution to infinite
games was partially if they mess you up
once then they mess you up forever but
the mathematics a forgiving people is
better how do we square with that with
corporate ethics so I understand that
all of us are fallible we're human
beings and even highly ethical companies
the people in those companies will do
unethical things but the difference is
is it's not it doesn't become a culture
it doesn't become a culture of unethical
behavior there might be ethical lapses
in which case the organization swoops in
and says hey guys we don't do that
or they take immediate responsibility as
soon as it's discovered they don't wait
for the scandal they don't wait to be
caught they don't do the cover-up they
take responsibility that's the big
difference
the problem isn't ethical lapses the
problem is how we deal with those
ethical lapses and when we talk about
being forgiving in my definition of the
responsibility business we say companies
have to be responsible for the decisions
they make and if they take no
responsibility and those decisions cost
them the business in other words it's
forced to drop out of the game because
of such extreme unethical behavior isn't
that isn't that ok and isn't that
justified and again it's largely a
leadership problem you know the people
the good news is you know when Circuit
City went bankrupt for example you know
the people who left Circuit City
wouldn't got jobs at other other places
best buy and things like that we will
continue to to play in the game and
sometimes these companies do deserve if
they're highly highly unethical also one
of the things that I I struggle with is
in the law we consider a corporation an
individual right and yet so often when
companies are caught doing on ethical
things they negotiate these deals where
they're they don't have to admit
phonce ability they simply make a path
and don't have to emit responsibility I
find that troublesome can you imagine if
if one of your friends did something
highly unethical to you they lie to you
they cheated on you something whatever
it was and they simply said I'll buy you
dinner but I'm not going to admit
responsibility I'd rather they admit
responsibility not buy me dinner
most malpractice cases are simply
because the doctor refused to apologize
isn't that crazy true fact
and it's an extrude and extremely high
number I can't remember the exact
statistic but it's something like 60 70
80 % of malpractice suits so I think
forgiveness is fine and I'm not remember
I'm I'm I'm I don't want us to rail
against Milton Friedman I want us to be
for something else and it isn't infant
game it is a game of bumps and and and
as we go along the way Patricia
haloo 'b what is the best way to learn
about and teach capitalism as it was
originally intended are there any books
you recommend Adam Smith's three volumes
of The Wealth of Nations is impossible
it's not useful there are really good
summaries the I use a really good
summary when I was getting my
information that comes from the Adam
Smith society they have academics who
sort of explain it all it's still two
hundred and something years old it's
written like that I think you made a
very good point which is one other thing
the problems is we don't teach this we
teach Milton Friedman form of capitalism
in our in our in our schools and our
business schools and I think we need to
teach this this more evergreen this more
infinite form of capitalism I think I
think you hit the nail on the head it's
not that are there any books that I
recommend it's that the books need to be
written new books need to be written
remember we've been following this
broken form of capitalism that we have
now for 50 years 40 40 some odd years so
knowing 50 years yeah so we need new
books you're yes yes and I think a lot
of the books that we're talking about
you know in least in amongst my peers
when we talk about you know what Bob
Chapman's book everybody matters
fantastic introduction to that book by
the way
[Music]
I think that's the though it's not
called that
I think these books that many of us who
are on here embrace I think that it
touches upon indirectly the form of
capitalism we want but you're right I
think we need new textbooks Oh getting
questions about my banana t-shirt so in
our organization okay well to give you a
little pre so have you ever had that
experience we were sitting in a meeting
and someone makes their point but they
keep going and going and everybody
understands but they just keep going and
going and nobody wants to interrupt or
knows how to interrupt because they
would want to be rude and so we just sit
there and comfortably as they keep
talking or you're sitting in a meeting
and somebody's talking about something
that has nothing to do with anything
that this meeting about is about they've
just got they've gone off subject and we
don't they don't even taking a breath we
don't know how to interrupt them and
because we feel like we're being rude so
in an hour on our team we came up with
this thing called banana which is when
somebody has made their point or if
they've gone off topic you can interrupt
them any time you just say banana and
it's just a more polite way of saying we
get it or you've got off-topic let's get
back on and we use it all the time
so if I'm going on too long in my
answers you can just type banana and
I'll move on to the next but that's what
the man is and I think we still set them
on that sell them on our website don't
we yes so if you want a banana t-shirt
you can visit our website under the
schwag tab and there's a banana t-shirt
there you can have exactly like this one
because that's where I got my other
questions
[Music]
what's what's her name or his tour
grossa
hello tour so tor has said that in their
country they became frustrated with
their own leaders at work and even their
own leaders of their country that
they're also finite minded how do we
transmit the infinite minded idea you're
doing it we have to talk about it the
great thing about dr. Carson's work is
it is so easy to understand we can
explain what the infinite game in the
finite game is in a couple sentences and
people understand it lickety-split and
so I think we have to talk about it we
have to talk about it we also have to
recognize that we have a lot of finite
minded players who are in leadership
positions because that's the system
we're in and we as much as we're
espousing our infinite ideals we have to
accept in this infinite game that some
of them will convert some of them won't
and some of them we just have to wait
them out and so I talk about this all
the time be the leader you wish you had
if we operate with a finite minded
finite mindset with our team for example
we do all the things that we're supposed
to do including preaching the definition
of an infinite game and that we're in
one eventually those people get promoted
or move out to other parts of the
company or move on to other companies
and we want them to take the lessons
they've learned from our team and go in
other words let's build a bench of
leaders for the next 20 years you know
hopefully we can change the minds of
some of the people in power ready
unlikely but the better option is to
build a strong bench of independent
minded leaders now then in the next 10
15 20 years is they start getting
promoted up and start taking over both
our nation's and our companies that they
will be more infinite minded so our
movement is working our words are
spreading keep reaching keep reaching
keep reaching
that's why we do this that's why even
book club exists it's to disseminate
ideas okay how quickly here's one from
condo how can well just ran away from me
way to go how can leaders leverage
affirmative actions to create a diverse
of an inclusive workplace without or
minimizing resentment or doubt from the
team or members
hello I think asking for help is the
thing to do I think that the more
ironically
inclusive
we can make these these changes I think
the better it goes I think having
discussions I think bringing people in
who are affected by it bringing people
who have been adversely affected by it
affirmatively affected by it and and and
not only having individual conversations
but bringing them in as a group and
saying this is what our goal is our
intention is to create a diverse and
inclusive workplace for all the obvious
reasons and because we believe that
different upbringings different
perspectives contribute to better ideas
and a better organization diversity in
all of its forms really really matters
and that's the kind of organization we
want we recognize that we can do better
than what we have been doing and we're
looking at all sorts of ideas to to make
sure that we are more inclusive and
diverse we're looking for ideas on how
we can do this and and I think the
leaders ultimately will have the the the
the final say but this but to take
council I think is imperative this goes
back to the story I think I've told
before of Nelson Mandela Nelson Mandela
is a very very important leader in the
world because different leaders from
different nations are viewed differently
depending on where you go in the world
but but Nelson Mandela is universally
regarded as a great leader so he's a
very very important case for us and he
was the son of a tribal chief and as a
and he was asked how did you learn to be
a great leader and he told the story
said I remember when I was a boy I would
go to tribal meetings with my father of
all the other tribal chiefs and he says
I remember two things one they always
sat in a circle and two my father was
always the last to speak and if you
think about that sitting in a circle
communicates equality of ideas
even if we know there are different
ranks in the room and number two so
often the the person in charge even
well-intentioned
will come in and say hey guys this is
what I'm trying to do this is what I
what I want to do this is what I think
we should do what are your opinions I
want to know well but the time they've
told you their ideas it's too late you
either muddied the waters or you or
you've made people feel that their
different ideas aren't don't matter
and so what's way more effective as four
leaders say this is the vision that I
want to achieve I'm interested in your
ideas and then
nothing about what they think we should
do and go around the room and let
everybody speak and that the
responsibility of the leaders to ask
questions for understanding but not to
make anybody feel that their ideas are
invalid by the way they can think
they're invalid some ideas are crazy but
the point is as two things happen one is
that leader gets the benefit of all
these different perspectives which
altered ultimately make them better
informed and two it makes everyone feel
like their ideas matter which because
they do so I would treat it the same way
good question
Pierre krarup did I pronounce that
probably badly sorry Pierre pare I say P
repair in Denmark when it comes to
humanities biggest challenges example
population growth poverty climate change
racial equality
assuming we may not have time to wait
for future generations for solutions are
there good ways to approach managers and
politicians when we believe that we are
going over the edge of a cliff but it
does not show up in our metrics yet or
are we simply or or we simply do our
part as best we can and tell those who
are willing to listen to hope for the
best
one of the biggest problems for a finite
minded species I mean let's be honest
we're all we all like to count results
we all like to be see the impact of the
things we're doing and when we're told
we have to do something that will
benefit future generations you know 40
years from now or this won't happen for
50 years but we have to act now you know
a lot of people gun they shrug their
shoulders you know up claim why I lied
to lose you know that it's not my
problem right after me comes the flood I
won't be here I think the most important
thing is two things one is we have to
change our own metrics and our metrics
should be about momentum rather than
absolutes especially with things like
this which are infinite in their own
respect there is no winning and losing
in the climate game and I keep saying
this which is we've got the messaging
completely wrong that's the second part
which is the messaging we've come
completely wrong first of all we called
it global warming sounds appealing it
also creates confusion especially when
you have colder than average winters but
I thought it was warming
because people confuse the climate and
the weather the weather and the climate
are not the same thing we should have
called it like climate cancer or
something because people react to
something like that but the other thing
is is is we keep talking about we have
to save our planet we have to save our
planet that is actually not true the
planet will be fine the planet will
survive no matter what life will
continue with us or without us what we
have to do is save our species we are
affecting the climate to the point where
we will make living conditions
impossible for our species because we'll
need to kill our own food sources or
make it impossible for us to live
because the the secondary and tertiary
effects of everything that we do you
over fish it kills Carl because Liz all
of these things happen that make it
impossible for us it's not it's not save
the planet it's save the human race and
that's what we don't talk about we
because unless you're environmentally
minded we're talking about saving the
planet doesn't appeal to everyone
talking about saving the human race
ensuring that your family will survive
hmm I think that's a much better
messaging so I think we got the
messaging wrong quite frankly so it's
it's it's not about saving the planets
about saving human race in creating a
planet that can sustain human life as
monks his life is everything of
everything else that's that helps us
survive - the flora and fauna included
so one is messaging the other one is how
we measure metrics we want to measure
metrics in terms of momentum
are we moving in the right direction as
opposed to absolutes I think that's very
helpful here's from the bridge house
book club from Berlin and Hamburg
Germany good nahban Alex Krakov wants to
know when I introduce myself to a
potential customer do I introduce myself
with my why or might just cause my why
is my origins or story far more personal
a Just Cause is probably a bit more
marketing visionary what are your
thoughts it can go either way I do both
so depends on the mood I'm in depends on
the audience usually if it's a business
relationship I usually do the just cause
but not always
when people
what do you do I say I teach leaders and
organizations how to inspire people
which is a nicer way a more public way
of saying my why which is to inspire
people to do the things that inspire
them so together each of us can change
our world to the better to cumbersome
you know why is not always pretty the
foundation of a house has nobody was
pretty so my wife's wince when people
say say hey Simon what do you do I say I
teach leaders and organizations how to
inspire people if they believe what I
believe if they if they believe what I
believe they say that's amazing
inspiration that's incredible how do you
do that they hear the word inspire if
they don't believe what I believe they
say what kind of companies do you work
for so I immediately it helps me know
are they believers or non-believers in
my wife but very often the way I start
meetings whether I the one I'm the one
who called the meeting or whether I'm
the guest of the meeting I always say
let me tell you why I'm here or let me
tell you why I called this meeting let
me tell you why I decided to attend this
meeting it's because I have a vision of
the world that does not yet exist a
world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspired feel safe wherever they are and
end the day fulfilled by the work that
they do and I took this meeting because
I believe that this relationship this
partnership potentially doing business
together whatever it is could help
advance that cause and very quickly I'll
find out if people lean back and put
their arms up they're not into my cause
versus they lean and go Simon this is
very exciting we took the meeting for
the same reason so I guess I've just
answered my question the Just Cause is
probably more helpful in a business
context okay what else okay sure we've
come laughs such a good question the
question was how can young leaders
would-be leaders
maintain an infinite mindset and sayings
stay inspired when they're constantly
being bombarded with finite mindedness
and being beaten down and it gets
discouraging that's why this matters
which is none of us are strong enough
none of us has the mental
toughness to get through this alone this
is why we need each other remember the
reason we formed a book club was not
about reading the book it was about
doing something with others it was more
important that you formed a book club
even if it was one other person than it
was to simply read the book because it's
about the shared ideas on the
camaraderie and the team that matters
most because you will get beaten down
and you will get discouraged the
question is who you're gonna pick up the
phone and call I have a group of people
some of them I've become friends with I
met them because I wrote about them yeah
Bob Chapman Johnny Bravo Kip Tindell
some of these folks who I I wanted to
learn more about and I wrote about them
some of them have become my friends and
when I'm beaten down or not sure I can
do it or become discouraged or whatever
it is I call one of them and say I love
that you and I are doing this together
thank you for being there and they talk
I mean go listen go I did I did a
podcast with Bob Chapman go listen to
how Bob talks like I don't have to say a
word I can just pick up the phone and
say hey Bob and he says all the stuff he
said to me on the podcast that's who he
is it just oozes out of the guy and he
here Ian spires me and he gives me the
confidence and most important the
feeling that I am NOT alone and so
that's very essential here which is this
is an uphill journey we are trying to
completely change the system of the
economics and business practices that
have been firmly entrenched for 40 years
and it took 40 years it took 20 or 30
years for that system to become
entrenched it's gonna take us 20 or 30
years to entrench a different system
we're well on our way
I think we're 15 years away maybe 10 if
we're really optimistic but 20 at the
most this is a long journey and so we
have to have buddies we have to have
leadership buddies in this and so that's
what this is about this is one of the
benefits a book club is that read all
the names in in the live comments every
single one of those people there they're
on that we're on the same team too so
never feel alone make sure you have
someone you can reach out to when you
feel beaten down and remember all of us
have to contribute in a small way it's
not necessarily about doing big things
it's about doing small things on a daily
basis
that matters even more than the big
things consistency is often more
important than intensity going to the
dentist twice a year intense won't keep
your teeth from falling out if you only
do that all your teeth will fall out
consistency brushing your teeth for two
minutes every single day even more
important believe it or not or at least
as important the consistency the little
things that seem innocuous are really
really important in this game so that's
what I would recommend okay how we doing
oh I like this one
Arun Suresh nice to meet you Arun can
the infinite mindset help in being more
open-minded and thereby learn more yes
yes yes such a great question and the
answer is a hundred percent yes okay and
for a couple of different reasons a
finite mindset hates surprises
hates uncertainty the finite mindset
likes to control things because if I can
control things it means that things will
go as predicted in other words finite
that's why finite mindset like short
timeframes we'd like short termism in
the finite mindset and we like to tell
people that our way is the best way
because more predictable that way
right that's what finite mindedness is
all about an infinite mind that infinite
mindset embraces uncertainty the they
find opportunity in surprises and
uncertainty things that are different
and are new are exciting and there's a
tacit understanding that I don't know
everything and other people know more
than I do
when I talked to dr. Carr's who first
articulated finite and infinite games he
explained it beautifully to me he said
with a finite mindset all the thinking
has already been done because you don't
want any surprises so for example in the
military or in sports athletes Olympic
athletes this is why they train and
train and train and train and train
they're constantly practicing practicing
training and training trying to make
sure that they've thought about every
eventualities because they don't want
any surprises and when they get into
into a situation combat or competition
they all say the same thing you have to
not think you have to let go and you
have to rely on your training you have
to rely on muscle memory in other words
predictable right whereas an infinite
mindset as dr. Carson
to me the thinking begins at the moment
of surprise so you don't actually fall
back on something you go oh this is
completely new what are we gonna do and
you start looking for new ways and you
become a curious and investigative and
you see this you see how in especially
in business companies try to solve
different problems the same way they try
to solve new issues the old way they
used to doesn't work the infinite
mindset says boy this is totally new
we're gonna have to do totally new
things are we prepared to do something
totally new that's a future chapter
that's existential flexibility but yes
yes yes yes an infinite mindset
absolutely keeps our minds more open to
things that are different new strange
uncertain surprises all those beautiful
wonderful things in fact when I say
those words do those words scare you or
do those words excite you uncertain is
that scary or is that exciting Jordan
Harper I like this one because I think
this is so realistic how do we recognize
in ourselves when we may be leading too
heavily from a finite mindset are there
signs we can look for remember the
infinite game is not the absence of
finite games finite games are very
important in the infinite game because
we need to have short-term victories
things that we can measure things that
we can plan the infinite the infinite
game is the context within which that
exists I've talked about this in
previous chapters think of it more like
a lifestyle I want to be a healthy
person one of the things I want to do is
lose some weight
finite goal finite finite mindset this
is my arbitrary weight I want to be this
is the arbitrary tape date I want to hit
it by but it's to be healthy it's
something more infinite it's something
more ongoing and so the question isn't
you know do you want to be one or the
other totally we're no one's purely one
or the other but if you find yourself
leaning towards too much of the finite
some of the things you can look for is
are you trying to be overly controlling
are people saying to you stop trying
stop trying to control everything mmm
that might be a sign are you operating
out of fear are you making decisions out
of fear inspiration are you make though
that would be a
mindset thing are you playing defense or
offense are you making decisions in
response to what your competition did or
are you making decisions to help advance
your your your cause regardless of what
your competition did these are these are
clues that there might be a little too
much finding my finite mind in this it's
good to understand what our company is
doing is not necessarily good to change
our path simply to react to them this is
what happened to Boeing by the way they
were so worried about what Airbus was
doing that they upset their own schedule
for the 787 they'd be kept doubting
themselves and that that that platform
can having so many delays and delays and
delays because they were not worrying
about their platform and their vision
they're worrying about what Airbus was
doing same with the 737 max they were so
obsessed with making their short-term
financial goals they actually produced a
plane that was dangerous so also check
the ethics of the organization excessive
finite mindedness will breed excessive
amounts of ethical fading which we will
discuss in a future chapter okay let's
see what else we have Simon we scamp a
good name the Simon part I mean how can
we motivate people who think that they
know it all and never think with the
group but always know it know best
just because that they are high in the
pyramid the so when you deal with
somebody who's more senior than you who
thinks they have all the answers and
seem to be close minded to the opinions
of others how do you direct treat them
well like anybody attacking them doesn't
work telling them that they're wrong
doesn't work validating their point so
it doesn't matter where there somebody
is in the in the hierarchy it's the same
up or down the hierarchy you want to
validate someone's opinion first I would
say that that's an interesting point of
view can I can I share something I was
thinking because very often what we do
is we tell them that their thinking is
wrong as opposed to saying I have a
different I have an alternative
perspective that might contribute I find
that that has been very healthy
I've dealt with people who much more
alpha than me and they've told me that
I'm right and I sort of nod my head and
I I go that's interesting you know one
of the things that's happened in my life
and I make it really personal to me so
it's less of an attack and they might be
more open-minded to listen when I say
and one of the things that I've observed
or I've I've been reading that's made me
very interesting and I make it a little
more objective or a little more personal
and I take them out of the equation so
their ideas are not are not part of my
equation so they feel less attacked bill
poon Philippines
I've eaten balut I didn't get through
the whole thing I will admit I got
through some of it I couldn't do it
how does playing with an infinite
mindset act as a moral compass again
we'll touch upon this in way more depth
when we get to the chapter on ethical
fading but one of the things in infinite
mindset does is actually helps us stay
more ethical believe it or not it an
integral and an infinite mindset is
actually an insurance policy against
unethical behavior or at least taking
its it's nasty grip and becoming
acculturated inside the organization
because when we're driven by our cause
we understand this is a long road when
you have an infinite mindset you
actually are forced to consider
secondary tertiary effects finite
mindset we just care about right now we
care about the reaction we get now we
care about the results we get now I'm
gonna pull this lever and this is gonna
happen that's all I care about an
infinite mindset inherently because
we're forced to look multiple steps
ahead and say okay if I pull this lever
and this happens here that'll make this
happen there this will make happen there
do we really want to do that I'll tell
you an extreme example of thinking about
secondary and tertiary effect so in in
the United States Marine Corps this is
I'm sure this is the the the case where
all the branches I just happen to know
this case from the Marine Corps it used
to be that a Marine if they wanted to
change their death benefits had to fill
out a form
probably in triplicate and get their NCO
to sign off on it and if their NCO
looking at the form said you want to
take your mom off your death benefits
that NCO is gonna look up and say what's
going on are you okay in the name of
of reducing bureaucracy red tape and
saving money the Marine Corps digitized
that process so now a Marine needle all
they need do is log on to the intranet
go on and change their death benefits
and that's it done money saved
bureaucracy reduced fantastic we love
that
however the Marine Corps also discovered
that well over 90% of Marines will
change their death benefits within one
week of a suicide attempt and we've
removed the human being we've removed
the human being from interjecting and
that in that transaction so did we save
money yes did we reduce bureaucracy
yes did we reduce red tape yes although
things good yes was it worth the money
we saved probably not and so we have to
consider that sometimes the problem
we're aiming to solve might create a new
problem and that's what it means to
consider secondary and tertiary defects
and sometimes it's not worth the money
we save or the money we make so one of
the things an infinite mindset helps do
is protect against that okay we're gonna
do I think one last question who wants
to bet who wants to win stab at that
cleanup yes the RAF girls we've heard
from them before ebony yeah good hello
Sarah Nichol I think we heard from you
last week what would I say to Milton
Friedman if I could speak to him today
that is such a good question I would
actually just wanna I would want to sit
and ask him how he came up with his
ideas I want the background story my
guess would be that Milton Friedman is
an academic in fact I know he wasn't
academic he was an economist and not a
business owner and and sometimes making
observations from an academic tower may
be good in theory but not good
practically I'd be curious to I'd just
be I wouldn't want to it's not that what
I want to say to man I won't have a
discussion with him I like having
discussions with people that I disagree
with I want to learn from people I
disagree with there may be some
foundations that are that are
fundamentally true but the expression
was was false and I want
I want to be open to his ideas because I
want him to be open to my ideas so I
would be respectful of what he had to
say and I'd want to learn more that's
what a conversation with Milton Friedman
would go like I hope he might hate me
and be mean to me I don't know I'm sure
he was a very nice man don't know never
met him
thank you everyone for joining I really
do love these I really do look forward
to these and we're gonna be back here
next Friday July 24th 1 p.m. Eastern
Time
we will be on LinkedIn Facebook and
YouTube we're going to be doing chapters
6 & 7 so chapter 6 is will in resources
chapter 7 is trusting teams so we're
gonna start really getting into the
thick of it which is great this has been
really fun the whole idea of our form of
capitalism that the form that we have
now was not this is not written in stone
and and our broken form of capitalism we
can be pro capitalists and want to be
true capitalists capitalists based on
the ideas of that the the purpose of
capitalism is consumption not production
that it's about the consumer not the
producer that it's about the customer
not the company and the idea that that
that shareholders they don't really own
the company it's a different definition
just just because it's it's not like a
private company that they if they're
gonna treat our if they're gonna treat
our companies like like rental cars then
why should we take advice from them
they're not our owners ok what was I
saying yeah so book club next Friday
24th 1:00 p.m. please send in your
questions and photos if you have photos
of your book club or over FaceTime
resume or whatever you use love to see
that as well that's really fun for us to
see please send your questions and
photos of your book clubs to book club
at simon Sinek dot-com and you can also
turn in here and we'll do some live
questions if you want to rewatch any of
this get any of this or share it with
someone who missed it all of these are
available on YouTube Facebook and
LinkedIn so feel free to go back and
watch these recordings if you want to
dive further into these concepts and
learn to adopt an infinite my
set our amazing team has started
producing classes to help people adopt
some these mindsets and they're up live
on our website Simon Singh Kham and
because I love all my friends who come
to book club we have a special discount
code 20% off that you can use anywhere
you want on the website sorry oh you can
use it on all the classes doesn't work
on the schwag sorry you can use
different systems you can use it for any
of the classes this is exclusively for
book club use the discount code book
club rules book club rules because it
does and get 20% off classes over there
and that's good for the month of July we
have classes on ooh yes we're ready just
this just in we already have classes on
how to advance a just cause and a how to
build trusting teams and study your
worthy rivals the trusting teams one is
gonna be really interesting riches on
that one right yes so a former Navy SEAL
who introduced me to the idea if you
read in the infinite game we'll get to
it later the idea of trust versus
performance I'm the guy who first
introduced me to that idea rich Divini
he's the guy who's is teaching the class
and building trusting teams really
really good class really really good guy
thank you for joining
again remember book club is not about
reading a book it's about doing
something together find a friend for my
book club have a discussion use the book
simply to spur conversation and ideas
and with that I'll say take care of
yourselves take care of each other I
love seeing you can't wait to see you
next week